[Musique]
merci sans le jingle secor booth s'est
pas où mais bon ça va ça passe ça passe
ça permet quand on veut et avec nous lui
ici c'est apparemment déjà qui va partir
alors je vous le dis comment ça va se
passer
il ya des bûches vous allez devoir tirer
les bûches à chaque fois celui qui a la
plus longue bûche et qualifié premier
quart de finale gilles contre daniel
ouhlala les boggies contre daniel pialet
[Applaudissements]
embauches d'ici là précise t on
mettez vous sur le côté mettez-vous
comme ça pour couvrir côté bah oui
prenez une douche sa peluche je veux
bien que vous méritez pas dire qu'elle
est longue à hasnon patate mais quand
même
voilà attendent alors à quoi j s'il bat
ça après vous mettez buts contre
bus contre bush haïti où je contrôle et
je gagne elle est lumineuse une
qualifiée merci peuvent daniel vous
plaît vous partez aller faire un tour à
la machine prenait non mais c'est pas à
huy
la bûche était cassée demande bien
comment tu peux la poussée père noël tu
ça se resserrait away c'est ce qui se
dit content d'être là de l'autre côté la
produire non d'abord l eau douce bûche
alors la bûche pas dit john l'a vu à
blanc la salle où s'était plus rendu
donc j'ai eu le tact éliminé gadet le
calice et baume au coeur à la
réclamation
je vous mets sera terminée merci à la
gauche au 2e 2e combat qui a la plus
longue bûche kelly contre rennes on
allait à l'essai attention qu'elle y
mettez vous sur le côté sion a dit
qu'elle était prenez la butte mais kelly
elle est vraiment mais c'est ok c'est
bon parce que il faut bien qu'on voit
kelly merci mon raymond et à lefka sinon
elle a une petite douche ah bah ouais ça
c'est la bûche ça c'est là bas dans la
page l'air hagard sinon mais j'ai vu
c'est raymond kelly éliminé kelly
vous êtes alors laponie tout comme
daniel attention troisième quart de
finale delphine contre mathieu ya deux
matches des beaux gosses fait la
télévision c'est pas été moi même
s'était fixé des fins non appariés t on
en est au diable merci choisit bien la
laine baseball à bienne va être longue
ah oui il était normalement il a la main
lourde et dur annoncé longue et dure
attention olala c'est moi il est même
filmé mais attendez c'est la mienne il
ya un truc là et sur une bombe mais les
sous sols mais nos solutions mais
c'était le seul merci à les verser la
copie des qualifi attention y'a
quatrième quart de finale
il y aura trois personnes benjamin
christine et bernard a qualifié moi
j'aimerais christine et bernard
attention on y va on laisse le style
d'abord prendre sa bûche à lui plaît
allez on y va la aignan christine qui a
la plus on pourra préfecture celui qui
gagnera la finale surprise sur toutes
les deux minutes diop et giorgio qui est
notre mentaliste lui apparemment il a
fait une prédiction il sait qu'il va
qualifié pour la la on verra si c'est la
bonne prédiction
oui merci merci d'inattention un petit
but attention allez vas-y bernard
bazille bernard wuthrich a déjà une
bague christine kristin éliminés
[Applaudissements]
kelly et chris hickey savait la vérité
merci marché qu'est ce qu'elle dit là
bas
merci mon bac j'ai souvent dit attention
on va passer à la première demi finale
la première demi-finale va opposer
daniel benaissa n'a pas joué non mais
non mais parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas venir non seulement l'équipe
s'il vous plaît mais laïc donc vous êtes
voilà vous êtes là vous faites sans
porter l'attention des quarts de finale
daniel qui avait gagné le premier quart
contre eux raymond daniel rémy le match
et les gens là gens qu'on aime allez
vas-y mon bébé à les attentions
aulas attention c'est à dire ces choses
là at war et vous allez vas-y mon réveil
vas-y mon chéri à l'heure où la finale
[Applaudissements]
déjà des ruelles castaldi contre
quelques unes des excuses à une petite
pression heures d'errance j'ai le droit
de voter ans tu viendras sans tomber qu
en laponie jean-michel verra sans son
amoureux en mai à tout non mancunien
tout à l'heure où j'adore et celui ces
maudits la survie n'a pas encore choisi
les chambres qui va avec qui j'aimerais
prendre celle ci est classé salut tu
peux nous non alors à toi de catus et
bruxelles allez on y va vite s'il vous
plaît allez voilà ça liam et noel très
très grande tu là
[Applaudissements]
attention la fnac et au vasco ccra
jolies filles italiennes ou d'acide
il y aura une jolie fille en laponie
match eric c je t'embrasse hand tu sais
que je t'aime
ouais bah ça ne viendra pas seul et
maxime ont déjà gagné leur billet pour
la peau du jeune fille décide pas en
laponie je t'aime beaucoup de gens
calmes toi dans ma ville
est-ce que je peux laisser tirer jean
michel amat l'échalas sait tirer comme
ça c'est bon merci allez vas-y vas-y
dadié bon alors daniel vanier tires tu
abuses tires tu abuses dire tu abuses
daniel
[Rires]
attention si vous devez au choix qui
allait plus loin et ça ce mandat c'est
la plus petite bûche qui gagne
maintenant c'est la plus longue
delphine celles nécessaires sont moins
flatteurs daniel sery c'était prévu
comme enjeu jusqu'à ces attentats temps
je vais la sortie à temps de les
ressortir de l'autre côté les thales est
au choix un choix sage de daniel way cdc
les visages
radiall gaz
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez attendez les chéris
attendait les séries parce que y'a
giorgio un bilan d au moins une
prédiction giorgio on rappelle que tu es
mentalist années précédant leur dieu
rappelle que tu mentalist merci cette
fois c'est pour moi voilà alors tant
biotois est ce que tu avais pronostics
et daniel comme dans le gagnant de
l'appel et que c'était une femme qui
allait le gagner
d'accord mais tu vois des gens on savait
que c'était pas de le castaldi voilà et
après daniel je voulais c'est le
découvrir c'est juste ouvrir hommes
voilà tiens ça c'est là qu'il a lu tous
les noms dans la voix alors regardez
bien c'est à dire qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quoi ça comme ça on va se mettre à
la paix à l'intérieur d'eux du coffre il
y a on est ouverts vite un copain le
vainqueur soit le vainqueur sera pas ce
que je dois faire avec c'est une femme
sam
ah ouais bah c'est assez bien voilà on
est vraiment ça c'est bon déjà sur deux
une chance sur deux roues merci beaucoup
voilà bravo
justin est ce que tu peux aussi te plaît
prends des coups mais plein de trucs
lessive à super besse et côté paillettes
attention
[Applaudissements]
mais centrica d'ordre tout chez moi chez
toi alors georges bédard venir nous
faire des poètes à des coûts facturent
bien mon père riba sétois non mais pour
nous à la crise et à l'avenir on a peu
n'y avait alors apparemment un boss
ouais il ya eu la montagne jamais autant
senti mentalement avant sa mort la
sécheresse je suis prêt je suis prêt je
suis prêt à y aller gagner c'est
delphine qui dira également on sera dans
la même chambre
alors là je croise les doigts j'ai
appuyé cherry bomb leur père alors avec
daniel bravo danièle jean-michel et
maxime partent avec mme en laponie pour
la sto je ne vous cache pas je suis bon
moment
[Applaudissements]
ah ah